[Applause]
[Music]
you're gonna teach us how to do
Riverdance
I assume exactly Riverdance is like the
end-all be-all of step dancing and it's
like girls with curly wigs did you bring
any of the little curly wigs I didn't
know okay look at Ned's gross teeth
compared to those pearly makes my teeth
look awful we're gonna roll our
shoulders back put superglue on our arms
keep those in and we're gonna put them
right at the side seams are you grabbing
your butt no you grab your butt it no no
but accidents just like I mean work
we're beginners so like wit like if it
helps us could we just drive our butts
very beginners hold on to their shirts
that's great that's our Freddy's day
we're having a certain start of this
problem forever our left foot all the
way up to our butt yeah
this is a step for fiber this is like
the first thing you learn great all
right for for jackasses
[Applause]
how would you rate us all individually I
think your guys's guests up Eugene being
the best might have been true all right
these guys are gonna need lots of
practice and work so if they want to
impress her co-workers may the luck of
the Irish be with them
who do you think's gonna look the most
adorable on a vest am I supposed to
answer that as someone who dances I
didn't realize Irish stepdance was
really really really hard and that it
takes a lot of powerful gluteous skills
yeah I feel like my butt is so much
hotter and tighter mm-hmm mostly I gotta
say I just want to make same crowd
named James Dean I'm 90% yeah 10%
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I've found that coordinating all of my
linens at once is nearly impossible but
focusing on just two just two of my four
limbs has been a real plus in my dancing
ability
there's something about eight-year-old
Ned that saw Riverdance on TV and was
inspired I think a little bit of that
joy was rekindled today it challenges
your body in places like muscles I
didn't know it'd be challenging by
tapping around Eugene come on Eugene
Eugene we're not doing
I almost slipped at one point I thought
I was gonna bust myself but none of it
mattered all you did was smile
they picked your feet up and you danced
the time to the music I just thought
about these fancy fancy fancy tasty
tasty heart stars and horseshoes clovers
and blue moon pots of gold and rainbows
and Zane's teeth
I said pots of gold right the videos
done